the outdoors there's a new way to get
hitched right here in the wedding
Capitol and his pop-up style so let's
welcome wedding planner Mackenzie Taylor
to show us her unique Cactus Collective
concept I like to call it how are you
I'm good how are you good welcome to the
show I'm so excited to tell people about
this very cool thing you're doing but
first let's talk about Cactus Collective
you're the owner of this of this event
planning company or business I should
say
um what's your approach to weddings yeah
so our Approach at Cactus Collective
weddings is to do Scenic microwettings
and allotments and we're all inclusive
all inclusive what does that mean so
that means that we provide vendor all
the vendors for your ceremony for each
of the events so the minister the
photography florals and the venue
typically that is music to a bride and
groom's ears I bet um now this is this
is fun way to say this is a fun way to
say it you're about to fill a dry lake
bed with love yeah I like it
yeah so so what we're actually doing is
we were finding that couples were
experiencing a lot of pain points when
it comes to weddings so they were having
a hard time hiring and vetting vendors
and then they were also you know having
a hard time finding a venue and a date
and then they were you know having a
hard time finding a theme so what we
decided to do is we decided to put
together a pop-up wedding event so we
picked the dates we picked the themes
and we've secured the venue and all the
vendors that is incredible we're seeing
beautiful footage right now of it um
explain the location the El Dorado dry
lake Bend yeah so El Dorado dry lake bed
is very versatile super photogenic and
it's about 30 minutes for the Las Vegas
trip so endless Horizons and beautiful
sunsets now the pop-up event is a span
of three days yep what are those dates
because they're significant yeah they're
very significant as you know Las Vegas
is beautiful in the fall so we picked
three fall dates October 1st October
22nd and November 11th which is a very
very popular date 11 11 2022. absolutely
um now because the space is you just saw
it it's vast it's huge I would assume
it's very versatile so you can do a lot
with it over the three days each day
will look different right yep so it will
explain how the process goes and then
how couples will get married there so
how it will work is we've already
selected the dates reserve the venue
like I said and then we've picked themes
so we picked a classic romantic theme
okay um another day is going to be a
Chic fall theme and then my personal
favorite is the modern Bohemian theme so
what will happen is you reserve us and
we'll fill in your timeline for you
we'll get you your minister and your
photographer and all the vendors and the
florals I mean it's it's going to be a
luxurious experience trust me but all
you have to do is show up and have the
time of your life now can you bring your
friends and family how does that work
yes so you can bring friends and family
um and they can enjoy it with you that's
so cool that is so cool now you said
it's only about 30 minutes away so it's
a quick drive for everybody
um you know how do they plan for this
kind of pop-up wedding yeah so you can
plan
um by inquiring online and then we we
reserve all the vendors for you but if
you want to get out there if you want to
take your family and friends out that's
a good idea definitely get some
Transportation it's much easier on
everybody but we provide all the
logistics for the day as well okay and
what about the this is your very first
pop-up event with Cactus Collective yeah
what are the few what's the future of
this pop-up concept I have a lot of
great ideas
he was like don't get us started but
um so we've experimented with multiple
different kinds of locations maybe
weekend experiences okay
um kind of full full scale full service
so alternate locations in other regions
even so yeah this is so cool yeah goals
go goals
how does one make a reservation and get
something get hitched up there in the
dry in the dryer dry like a lake yeah
it's right of like so all you have to do
is go to cactus-collective.com and we
have a very special URL for your
Watchers
um and you can fill out an inquiry there
I think it's right there on the screen
there we go um and we'll our team will
walk you through all the processes and
take you through all the steps to make
this a reality for you wow dry lake bed
of dreams I love it
right I know Kendall's into you all
right